l'equazione dell'equilibrio allora a
dirla così tra di noi cioè non è che io
sia proprio la più adatta né a parlare
di equazione perché io la matematica
siamo le famose rette parallele che non
si incontrano mai fin dai tempi del
liceo
bene in un certo senso anche di
equilibrio perchè pensate che io ho
cambiato due università nel mezzo ci ho
messo una bella esperienza all'estero
giusto per scoprire il volto imparare
una lingua quelle cose meravigliose che
si fanno a vent'anni poi sono entrata
nel mondo del lavoro con un certo direi
un certo successo con certe
soddisfazioni ma la mia permanenza media
in una stessa organizzazione diciamo è
stata di un annetto
lo sport parliamo dello sport io sono
una grandissima appassionata di sport
nella mia vita mi sono appassionata
visceralmente ad uno sport per 5 6 mesi
e poi via da qualche altra parte si può
escludere diciamo forse la mia ultima
passione è stato rugby che è durata un
pò di più ma diciamolo in tutta
sincerità sono state più il terzo tempo
le trasferte in giro per l'italia le
serata il venerdì con la squadra che
gioca insieme e ora negli ultimi due
anni mi sono trasferita a ben due volte
dall'italia agli stati uniti dagli stati
uniti all'italia
e a fine febbraio riparto e allora non
lo dice ma scusami cioè hanno invitato
mica tanto obbligato a parlare
dell'equazione dell'equilibrio poter
riportare qualche altro argomento se non
era il tuo è invece no perché io nasco
da problem solver come forse qualcuno di
voi avrà visto sulla mia abilio ma in
realtà adesso faccio la balance coach
probabilmente sono l'unica in italia
quindi aiuto le persone a trovare il
perfetto equilibrio e questa possibilità
mi è stata data proprio da un lato dalla
mia preparazione il proprio in soldi che
poi vedremo come ma dall'altro proprio
da questa mia esperienza strampalata con
l'equilibrio perché mi sono resa conto
che quando si parla di equilibrio
generalmente la nostra mente va dai
mondi ben precisi la meditazione
un'alimentazione equilibrata
un esercizio fisico costante che porta i
nostri muscoli il nostro corpo ad essere
in equilibrio
solo che questo è solo uno dei possibili
modi di trovare il proprio equilibrio
perché ci sono persone che per trovare
l'equilibrio hanno bisogno invece di con
un cambiamento continuo ci sono persone
che hanno bisogno di rischio continuo
per trovare l'equilibrio
allora con gli strumenti che avevo mi
sono messa un pò a studiare questa
dinamica come funziona l'equilibrio e
come mai le persone hanno così
difficoltà a trovarlo ed è nata diciamo
così l'equazione dell'equilibrio e
quindi un'attenzione particolare a
quelli che sono i fattori che se gestiti
nella maniera migliore per noi stessi ci
permettono di arrivare all'equilibrio
giusto perfetto per noi però non in
assoluto
la seconda domanda che potrebbe sorgere
spontanea è ma perché devo cercare
l'equilibrio
la risposta è pesata e semplice allora
l'equilibrio a ciò che più facilmente si
può accompagnare alla felicità una
persona equilibrata
è una persona che tende che facilmente a
definirsi felice e poi perché in
equilibrio
migliora le nostre performance cioè
senza che ce ne rendiamo conto una
persona equilibrata e più efficace e più
efficace al lavoro è più efficace nella
propria vita privata
questa è la ragione per cui si cerca
l'equilibrio e per me essere equilibrati
che cosa vuol dire
fondamentalmente vuol dire questo andare
a letto soddisfatti della gioia nella
trascorsa e svegliarsi con la giusta
energia con la giusta grinta per
affrontare la giornata che verrà
e allora
ora vi faccio vedere questa famosa
formula questa famosa equazione
dell'equilibrio però prima deve chiedere
scusa a tutti di ingegneri matematici
menti scientifiche che ci sono in sala e
che poi mi seguiranno su questo palco
perché credo nella mente esperta
inorridirà che cos'è questa l'avana 24
ma in realtà per me l'equazione è quello
che nel marketing si chiama cook è un
gancio qualcosa che mi serve per
agganciare la vostra attenzione su
questi fattori determinanti per
l'equilibrio di una persona e allora ve
la faccio vedere e ve la leggo
il senso fulfilment il senso di
appagamento
corrisponde al tempo suddiviso per le
priorità sommato all'otium
nell'accezione latina positiva di
diciamo dolce far niente e poi
approfondiremo tutto questo x
relazioni le relazioni funzionali delle
relazioni che funzionano che vanno bene
nella nostra vita
vista così sembra complicatissima ma ora
l'altra versiamo velocemente
attraversiamo tutti questi fattori per
vedere se vi posso dare qualche spunto
di riflessione non per vedere se
riuscirà in qualche modo ad agganciare
qualcosa per migliorare l'equilibrio
della voce partiamo dal tempo se io dico
tempo voi dite non li pasta mai vorrei
andare in palestra ma non tempo vorrei
organizzare una forma nono tempo lo farò
quando avrò tempo siamo sempre ad
inseguire il tempo solo che c'è una cosa
su cui porre riflettere con voi rispetto
al tempo ci avete fatto caso che nei
periodi più carichi della vostra vita
quando stai boksic mi vasti progetti più
importanti in momenti particolarmente
faticosi della propria vita personale
in realtà sono stati proprio quei
momenti quando dei momenti migliori per
andare in palestra fare a corsettina
organizzare la cena con gli amici
poi invece arrivano quei momenti un po
fiacchi
io mi ricordo per esempio dopo gli esami
all'università il cliente in quel
bellissimo circolo vizioso del meno fai
meno faresti non hai niente da fare ma
arrivi a fine giornata fai non ho avuto
tempo
di andare in palestra ma c'era tutto il
giorno a disposizione
questo scusate avviene perché
fondamentalmente funzioniamo un po mi
piace dire funzionare un po una macchina
ibrida molto mobili brita c'è bisogno di
un carburante dall'esterno un'energia
rientra dall'esterno poi però la
macchina ibrida cosa fa nel momento in
cui parte e comincia a consumare quel
carburante esterno in realtà produce un
certo quantitativo di energia diversa e
noi funzioniamo un po nello stesso modo
una volta ricaricate dall'esterno e
vedremo poi quali sono i nostri migliori
carburanti proprio mentre viaggiamo
riusciamo a produrre un'energia
parallela che ci permette di gestire
molto meglio il nostro tempo senza che
neanche ce ne rendiamo conto
le priorità anche qui è bellissimo è
sempre tutto urgente chi lavora in
ufficio
almeno 3 4 volte la settimana si sente
fare la battuta per quando l'ha
consegnato questo
e 30 anni che fanno la stessa identica
battuta non ride più nessuno eppure
tutte le settimane almeno 12 volte ci
tocca a sentirlo
noi viviamo e lavoriamo secondo il
principio di urgenza facciamo sempre
prima quello che è urgente e questo
provoca una forte frustrazione spesso e
volentieri prima di tutto perché il
piacere è sempre escluso dall urgenza
perché non confondiamo il concetto di
urgenza con il concetto di dovere paolo
invece il piacere deve essere una
priorità assoluta
perché è uno dei carburanti migliori che
possiamo iniettare della nostra auto
ibrida dall'esterno
e poi perché in questo senso di urgenza
che vediamo tutti i giorni non si lascia
abbastanza tempo per i progetti a medio
lungo termine i progetti più creativi i
progetti che ci appassionano di più che
ci danno un obiettivo
e allora la miglior cosa che si può fare
per far viaggiare questa auto ibrida e
per avere più tempo a disposizione nella
nostra percezione è riuscito ad essere
più efficace è proprio quello di
inserire ogni giorno tra le nostre
priorità almeno un piacere e almeno un
quantitativo di tempo dedicato ai
progetti a medio e lungo termine e poi
lo zoom
l'otium era inteso dai latini come il
tempo trascorso lontano dal negozio
quindi lontano dal lavoro
lo si era una prerogativa
dei nobili degli intellettuali chi non
poteva e non aveva proprio la
possibilità di usufruire dell'ozio
dell'otium erano gli schiavi
e allora provocatoriamente vi chiedo ma
se noi non siamo in grado di ritagliarsi
una giornata un quarto d'ora mezz'ora di
otium è che siamo schiavi di noi stessi
in qualche modo
lo vedete non è un carburante potente
come il piacere o potente come i
progetti a lungo termine
però è altrettanto necessario l'efficace
prima di tutto perché quando usiamo e
patate bene però su intendo fare niente
cucinare non ne voglio andare in
palestra non è su questi possono essere
dei piaceri che come abbiamo detto prima
sono fondamentali l'occhio al proprio
prendersi dieci minuti all'inizio poi si
spera di riuscire ad aumentare
per non fare niente assolutamente niente
e allora l'occhio ci permette prima di
tutto di ricaricarci perché non
consumiamo né su quasi nessuna energia
mentre pratichiamo rosso ii ci permette
di dare spazio al pensiero filosofico
quel pensiero che apparentemente non
serve a niente ma che invece è il
migliore allenamento per il nostro
cervello è forse la parte più importante
del nostro corpo e poi perché allo
stesso tempo ci permette di entrare
quello che io chiamo circolo virtuoso
della noia cioè annoiandosi durante
quest odio si ricomincia ad apprezzare
di più la produttività e quindi saremo
molto più lanciati quando ripartiamo e
poi ultimo ma forse più importante
le relazioni le relazioni le nostre
relazioni personali ci circondano
possono essere il peggior inibitore o la
più grande spinta al nostro successo
voi pensate a avere una soddisfazione
particolarmente importante un successo
particolarmente significativo al lavoro
ma tornare a casa e aveva una situazione
molto faticosa col partner con il figlio
con la mamma o quello che è
oppure pensate a stare lì a organizzare
un weekend della madonna con la con la
famiglia che è fidata ce ne andiamo ci
divertiamo con la spada di damocle del
lunedì quando dovrò rivedere il mio capo
e in questo momento siamo in pensione se
le relazioni non funzionano non ci
possiamo godere i nostri successi
e allora come ci si prende cura delle
relazioni in maniera strategica perché
non vuol dire che ci devono rimanere
simpatici tutti vuol dire vanno gestite
con attenzione prima di tutto facendo
caso alla questione del supporto noi
abbiamo bisogno di supporto e uno dice
ma come obbligo gli altri a tenere il
supporto è facilissimo tuco meraviglioso
tramite il coinvolgimento
impariamo a chiedere aiuto un'opinione o
un consiglio a chi ci circonda sulle
nostre sui nostri progetti anche se non
è direttamente coinvolto perché se noi
iniziamo trascinandosi dietro chi è con
noi
a un certo punto ci ritroveremo che sono
loro a spingere in avanti verso i nostri
obiettivi
il secondo aspetto
importantissimo è lo spazio bisogna
imparare a rispettare gli spazi degli
altri e ogni spazio è fatto di diritti e
di doveri
questo per dire non cadiamo nella
trappola del multitasking non cadiamo
nella trappola del lo faccio da solo lo
faccio io perché sono più bravo lo
faccio io perché sono più abituato ci
metto meno farò da solo chi sa spiegarlo
a te
in questa maniera stiamo invadendo lo
spazio dei doveri di qualcun altro e
stiamo invadendo lo spazio dei diritti
nostro
impariamo a rispettare gli spazi e
allora è in questo modo che si arriva al
famoso senso fulfilment senso di
appagamento
il senso di appagamento è quella
bellissima sensazione che si ha quando
qualcosa ci viene particolarmente bene
che attenzione non importa che sia una
promozione al lavoro un progetto che ha
riscosso il successo con
l'amministratore delegato
l'acquisto della casa della vita cioè
basta una ricetta che ci è venuta bene
basta un rebus che siamo finalmente
riusciti a risolvere basta la pacca
sulla spalla di un collega che di solito
ti guarda un po storto quello è già
senso fulfilment e il senso fulfilment è
la cosa che più si avvicina alla
felicità
noi volta cerchiamo la felicità come se
fosse un mostro sacro no da raggiungere
con chissà quali acrobazie la felicità è
quella che si raggiunge verso il senso
fulfilment quotidiano attenzione però
per essere funzionale alla felicità il
senso fulfilment deve essere diffuso è
inutile essere al top della carriera e
avere una situazione disastrosa a
livello personale ed è inutile avere la
famiglia del mulino bianco se non siamo
soddisfatti professionalmente quello che
dobbiamo riuscire a trovare è quella
linea
media mediana dissenso fulfilment che
sia diffusa su tutte le aree della
nostra vita
e allora io da problem solver prima e da
balance coach poi mi sento di lasciarvi
con un semplice suggerimento
usando una citazione che ho rubato e non
vi dico neanche da chi
non cercate la soluzione cercate in
equilibrio perché esso condurrà
esattamente alla soluzione che cercate